après la publication de l'étude de la
revue médicale britannique the lancet tu
montrant l'inefficacité de la
chloroquine dans le traitement du coït
l'organisation mondiale de la santé a
pris position sur le recours à cette
molécule contre le coronavirus d'exact
go la direction collégiale a décidé de
mettre temporairement oppose la section
hydroxy chloroquine dans le cadre des
essais solidarité pendant que les
données de sécurité sont examinés par le
comité de surveillance chargé de les
évaluer
les autres sections du programme d'essai
se poursuivent du côté de la france
le ministre de la santé olivier vers ans
avait demandé samedi au haut conseil de
la santé publique de se prononcer sur
l'utilisation de l'hydroxyde chloroquine
selon europe 1 l'avis du hcsp serait
défavorable ce qui engendrerait l'arrêt
dé prescription du médicament contre le
kobe de 19
un nouveau revers pour les partisans de
la molécule comme le professeur didier
raoult qui hier semblait déterminé à
continuer les traitements à la
chloroquine vous ai passé quatre mille
malades dans les mains croyez pas que je
vais changer parce qu'il ya des gens qui
font du big data qui est une espèce de
fantaisie complètement délirante qui
prend des données dont on connaît pas la
qualité qui mélange tout qui mélangeait
traitement dont on ne sait pas quelle
est la dose qu'on a donné six hommes
prenaient des cyclos qui l'on peut se
suicider avec un printemps trop comme
avec le doliprane de son côté donald
trump qui prenaient de l'hydroxyde
chloroquine de manière préventive depuis
deux semaines a décidé de stopper son
traitement
al'inverse le gouvernement brésilien
choisit de continuer de soigner ses
malades
avec ce médicament nous assumons notre
capacité en tant qu'organe directeur du
système de santé universel du pays de
suggérer une dose qui correspond à une
prescription sur et pour respecter un
autre principe de bioéthique
il s'agit de maintenir notre capacité à
garantir à tous les patients qui le
souhaitent ce qui est le rôle du sps le
droit d'accéder à un médicament
nous suivons donc avec calme et sérénité
nos lignes directrices il n'y aura pas
de changement dans la note d'information
élaboré le 20 mai le débat sur
l'hydrologie chloroquine ne semble pas
près de s'arrêter
ce médicament restera quoi qu'il arrive
très controversé